How many people do you think will be less?
Uh,
I'll say too,
I guess I'll just throw a number out.
If it's zero then hey,
that's my life already.
So it's
instead of,
hello,
I just put help.
Okay,
nice.
All right.
Okay.
Anyone who doesn't want to go on a blind date?
Leave the circle in three,
two.
Hello?
Oh,
hi.
I think I definitely prefer girls who have been in a relationship before or at
least maybe a long term relationship,
uh,
because they really kind of know what it's like to be in a relationship and
starting something new with somebody who's never had that.
It was a lot harder,
honestly.
Fair.
Wow.
Okay.
A lot of them out.
Oh God.
That's okay.
We'll go for the click bait first.
You know,
getting experimental in the bedroom is always fun for me.
That sounds like I'm Christian Gray by nothing too crazy.
I don't like,
like things getting boring.
I just like the position Robo Kingston.
Okay,
cool.
Got that out of the way.
Ethnicity wise,
I have zero preference.
Um,
I genuinely find it
any race culture.
But,
uh,
when it comes to like physical afternoons,
definitely prefer girls who are either a couple of inches taller than me or
shorter.
I don't mind it when it goes a little bit taller than me,
but if it's over like two inches maybe I feel a little bit weird.
Cool.
I don't like it when girls believe in horoscopes.
Um,
which is like the weirdest thing ever.
But I hate it when someone's like,
oh,
I'm a Libra.
I don't think Meta Click,
the moon's aren't aligned for this and this month,
so we can't really,
you know,
get Boba because we wouldn't click.
I hate that shit.
God's good.
Okay.
I liked girls who are into the arts in my Korean barns,
so people who are already down that path.
When we started dating,
when studying arts or anything within that field.
Careerwise that's something to talk about.
You know,
I can't talk about accounting because I don't know shit about accounting.
So definitely like someone who aligns within my interests within the arts,
whether that be music,
physical painting,
acting camera whenever.
Okay.
Sorry.
Hi.
Nice to meet everyone.
I'm going to talk to you Suzanne.
Nice.
Okay.
Nice to meet you,
Julia.
Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you guys.
Funny responses.
That was fun.
I was like,
fine,
but also terrifying.
I kind of wanted to shut myself that whole time.
I thought it was this thing that we're all compatible.
I was surprised at how many people had not been in a long term relationship.
Maybe I was too specific on my,
my dates,
but that was kind of interesting.
Just like,
you know,
from the get go.
Yeah,
I guess.
I guess the,
everyone's true colors comes out as time passes.
I guess getting the few preferences out first is kind of Nice,
but I can't really say that I would want to get in a relationship with somebody
based on just,
you know,
guidelines that I sat.
Yeah,
it's hard.
I'm not picky,
John,
you know,
uh,
I'm a lover of all beings.
That sounds fucking Tom,
as always,
love to hear what you think.
So leave your comments right there.
Be sure to follow us on Instagram so you know what we're up to describe.
Watch more videos rollout.